بالكاد من
المدفعية القادمة من حاملة الجنود المدرعة ،
سننتظر في هذا
القبو الصغير حتى ينتهي القصف ، ثم
يعتقدون أنه سيكون من الآمن المضي قدمًا
إلى المواقع الأمامية بعد بضع سنوات
بأمان للخروج إلى هذا الجيش  المخفر الأمامي على بعد
أميال قليلة من الوحل الخلفي كان صعبًا الليلة الماضية ، كان هناك
الكثير من القصف المدفعي ،
تخبرنا المناورة أن الجندي
لا يزال مصدومًا من هجوم صاروخي مضاد للدبابات ،
سنعود إلى السيارة في محاولة
للاقتراب قليلاً  الخطوط الأمامية
قبل عشرة أيام دفعت هذه القوات
الروس إلى الوراء حول الوحل الخلفي ، لكن
تقدمهم يتباطأ ويصعب
علينا الوصول إلى إشارة اتصال صغيرة في المقر الرئيسي ، حيث يستعد فوكس وهو
مزارع سابق لقواته
لمناوبتهم القادمة على خط المواجهة
لوقف الروس.  الوحل الخلفي من
تقديم مدى
صعوبة وصف هذه المشاعر ،
يقول إنه يمكنك تجربتها فقط ، ولا
يمكن للكلمات أن تعبر عنها ، إنها تقصف كثيرًا لأننا
نتحدث ، من الواضح أن هذه الحرب تلقي
بظلالها عليك فقط أن تنظر إلى
الجنود  وجوه هنا لمعرفة مدى صعوبة
هذه المعركة ، يبدون جميعًا بالية ،
يقولون إن الروح المعنوية مرتفعة ،
لكن وجوههم تحكي قصة مختلفة
نتحرك نحو مواقع أخرى
ونتوقف مع زيادة القصف ، وقد تم
إخبارنا للتو بالمكان الذي كنا
ذاهبون إليه  يتعرض لقصف عنيف ، لذلك
سننسحب من هنا ونذهب إلى
مكان آخر في مخبأ الكتيبة ،
يخبرنا القائد أن الروس
كثفوا قصفهم على قواته
منذ أن أطلقوا
أطنانًا من دبابات شظايا الذخيرة التي أطلقت
كل ما
سجلته طائراته بدون طيار.
النجاحات الأخيرة ولكن الآن الروس أعادوا
تجميع صفوفهم وفي لحظة صراحة
بعد الخسائر في الليلة السابقة
يعترف بأن الروح المعنوية تتراجع ،
فلنكن صادقين يقول إننا نقاتل
بشدة لأكثر من عام
خاض جنودي العديد من
المعارك ودورتين بالقرب من الخلف.
مرهقون لكننا نتحمل ما هو
فوق التل في هذا الاتجاه
أصبح درسًا موضوعيًا في كيفية
انتشار الثروة البشرية والذخيرة لروسيا
وأنه ما لم تحصل أوكرانيا على
دعم الأسلحة الحديث من حلفائها ،
فستكافح من أجل قلب التوازن  علامة
النداء فوكس ووحدته يتم تحميلهما
لأميالهم الصعبة في مقدمة ونهاية
الحرب للعودة إلى عائلاتهم ما
يدفعهم إلى القصف